the better question is though
what conversation are you having with
your girls though
after the man crashed right because
that's the truth that's the truth behind
it okay i will answer your question
because her respect for you is gone a
little bit yeah yeah is it though no
individually you know as speaking
speaking to the mic i'm not
i am not a very emotional person
so if if the man i'm with is overly
emotional more emotional than i am
we're not really on the same page but
i'm not putting aside anyone's emotions
because the same way you're saying okay
a man shouldn't cry oh like if he's
crying too much i get that but i'm not
saying if he comes to me christ me
because he's going through something i'm
not running i'm personally not running
to my goals and laughing about it i'm
not doing it because i've seen i've seen
a safe space where i know a couple that
that have that safe space and he has
credited to his woman and it's never
been a sense where she's ever gonna run
to anyone laughed about it so do you
think that women respect more
authoritative men
yeah domineering men or they respect
more feminine men than they do but a
dominant man doesn't mean he can't show
emotions no i'm saying about what what
get what gains a woman's respect
it's subjective
and i just did you know so i say what's
interesting is because the reason why
there are leaders in this world right
that people respect is because they
display those traits
um they display authoritative and
domineering traits and those men
generally have the pick of women
because the all women are attracted to
that generally an authoritative
domineering man they may say oh my god
it's toxic masculinity i know that god
that guy is part of patriarchy you know
how many you know many yeah that man's
got that i look at that are going for
him because women are attracted to
authoritarian figures women are
attracted to power
but that's part of the attracting that's
part of the attraction
you can be
it's true that's part of the attraction
someone who's dominant but a respectful
one that is there's one that just comes
in and says this is how it's going to be
right
that's nice because because in life
if you go to uni if you go to school
we're taught to respect authority go to
the police if you go to whoever is the
president's the kings
we are told to respect authority and
people that are authoritar that
authoritative figures
wish we're told yeah that those are the
people that we should be respecting and
then that power comes with attract that
power and authority comes of
attractiveness that's what that's what
women generally do people become
disrespectful and start doing things
they're not supposed to be doing
that level respect goes down
we're told that to respect the police
yeah but when they're doing things that
are going against what they're supposed
to be doing
you're like i can't respect you but nine
times i tend to please just bust open
the store right now you'll be silent as
a mouse
because i don't want that to happen to
me right it's not respectful exactly
exactly
but it's out of fear it's not out of
respect there's a difference from
fearing someone and respecting someone
but regardless
of my husband but regardless you're
gonna act in order and i'll never put my
situation around where i have to fear
him because it has to be a little bit
fair
i think there has to be a little bit of
fear
i feel
yeah
it feels good
guys
i'll explain why i'll explain why if you
think that you can do anything to your
husband and there's going to be no
repercussions and you don't respect him
so there has to be a little bit of fear
hang on hang on wait wait wait hang on
wait wait yeah but i'm saying but i'm
saying fear has to fear is part of the
authority figure because you fear what
may happen if you cross the line with
that authority figure so i'm saying
that's why there has to be a little bit
of fake just like if you say oh i love
my mum but i fear that when i was
granted because if i crossed the line we
should work my ass right whatever it is
there has to be a little bit of fear
that says listen if i cross a line to a
certain point i know they're going to be
whatever the repercussion is i'm not
talking about physical repercussion at
all i'm just talking about there has to
be some kind of repercussion to stop you
from crossing that line yeah to make you
know what if i do that
ah no you know i don't want to do that
there has to be that kind of thought
within people when it comes to authority
but when when the fear over like is
overcomes the respect when i'm the only
reason i'm listening to you like you
said your mom the only reason don't
listen the only reason i'm listening to
you right now because i fear that you're
going to beat me not because i'm not
because at this point i respect you
it comes to a point when the fear
overcomes the respect that you have for
the for the person then it's they don't
see them as dominant anymore you're just
scared that whatever's gonna happen is
gonna be severe consequences so like if
i'm with a man if i ever get to a
situation of a man i fear that something
like there's more fear to what he's
going to do then i respect him the
relationship is isn't going to be
okay so so when i say fear i think
people are getting it
in general yeah i'm saying like you said
i don't disagree
with a man of fear like you said i love
my mom but i fear her because i know
that she's
she's an authoritarian person so she has
she has authority over me as i've grown
up so i know that if i cross this line
there's going to be consequences whether
it is she takes my ipad away or whether
she
takes it no
but i'm saying once that fear becomes
more than just the level of respect
that's when we go into dangerous waters
i agree that's one i agree
with the police
of course you're gonna respect because
they have the authority but once it
becomes that like you said if they come
in now i'm sitting quiet because i fear
them not because i respect them
so if it so when it comes to
relationships right yeah so people build
bonds with one another right they love
each other right and
you're and if you two have had that
conversation about we're exclusive babe
i love you i want to marry you blah blah
blah the fear now becomes
if i do something
to if i do something way across the line
i will no longer have this relationship
i will no longer have this person in my
life this person will no longer love me
that is a fear so when i say fear fear
has to be part of a relationship to some
degree because if there's no fear then
the person will just do what the hell
they want yeah 100
but then that doesn't cover i feel like
that's a bit separate and then the
respect because if i respect for you
then i know that i would i wouldn't want
to cross that line because i respect you
because you are exactly because you're
you are the first person in the
situation
wouldn't want to is different than the
situation then coming to handle because
wouldn't want you no one wants to but a
situation
if i hold respect for you if you're dead
yeah i'm not going to do it to you but
unfortunately live streams
i've got an analogy for you um do you
respect god
i'm 100
do you fear god
i feel good yeah
do you see what
so you respect god and you fear god
what i think you're doing in your
argument is you're using the extremes of
a situation in order to justify your
point
so for example
if you're saying oh
we're talking about uh
having a small bit of fear and you use
the extreme of having a lot of fear for
someone to actually be able to do the
same thing that someone an authority can
do that's an extreme if we're just
talking about
authority in general there has to be a
some sort of fear in order for you to
have respect i totally get what you're
saying you are correcting what you're
saying but more so than anything with
the god analogy you respect god but you
also fear him
do you know what happens
when when a person does not fear the
person in the relationship
will and jada
oh